hey y'all it's center couch here in this
tight tuesday video
i'm going to be going over the included
plotting functions in
tidy models um what's really great about
the tidy models package is that it
basically has
everything you need when you want to do
some type of machine learning
and it includes some pretty nice plots
to use when you want to do some model
diagnostics
so i'm just going to go over a basic
modeling workflow
i've already coded everything out and
i've actually ran the script already
so that way we don't really wait for any
like run times or rendering
um we already have the objects created
um and i'm just going to show you just
some ways to plot out
um or to use the actual plotting
functions that are included inside tidy
models
so i'm going to walk through basically
each code chunk and then we're actually
going to see the plots and i'm going to
kind of explain
what each plot does and how you can use
it in your own
analysis so obviously the first package
we're going to be using is the tidy
models
uh we're also going to use stacks
because i've noticed that a lot of
people want to do a lot of
like ensemble stacked machine learning
models
we're going to use fine tune which is
also a different way we can
tune our models the vip package which is
used for variable importance
scores um we're also going to use tidy
posterior which is good for comparing
different models
and also model data which is a data
package that's included
with the titan model package i also have
the option set to tidy miles dot dark um
that's mostly for the financing package
but that's not really necessary for this
uh actual process
so um i decided to actually do two
different
uh data sets a regression and
classification data set
um so that's why i call in the two class
data
um just a simple binary classification
data set
um what's interesting about it is that
there's really nothing to kind of
extract out of it um just two features
a and b and the class so this is mostly
like kind of like a simulator
a simulated data set to use for my net
like analyzing
different model um algorithms and we're
also gonna use the aims housing data set
as
our regression data set so
classification data we're trying to
classify um class there's no real
background information for for what it
is
and then the regression data set is the
ames housing data set
where we're going to be predicting um
the uh the how the sale price of the
house
um since this is included with the
model data package uh i want to do some
checks just to see if there are any
missing values so in this case we don't
really have to do anything because it's
included
into this uh package and that what they
want to basically have you guys
do with these data sets is kind of just
a test out and learn
uh the tidy models function so i'm
pretty clean data set to actually work
with
so i create some dat basic data
partitioning you know using initial
split
um for the classification data set i
stratify base of class
again this isn't completely necessary
just because like this is a simulated
data set
so we don't really know what we're
actually trying to do with it it's just
a good thing for
um i guess a nice example
create the trained data sets to be used
in a pre-processing
and then we also create our k folds
cross validation sets
uh with the existing train samples
so for the actual pre-processing
pre-processing
uh the class recipe for the
classification um uh
data there's no real pre-processing
because there's only two features and
we're trying to
predict a binary outcome so in this case
it's just a simple
formula um which is not really something
you'd actually be doing in your own
workflows you probably have to do some
type of future engineering
but for this example you know let's keep
it a little bit simple
um for these other two recipes for the
regression problems
i wanted to basically do um your typical
um your typical preprocessing so
uh with the ames housing data set we
actually have a decent amount of columns
um so i wanted to basically remove any
columns that have near zero variants
uh any correlated features we do some
normalization some box
transformations uh we do some lumping in
the categorical variables
and then we dummy them out um i wanted
to make another recipe
or another preprocessing object where in
this case uh
in case you want to actually tune a
recipe uh which is definitely something
you do a lot when you're doing your
feature engineering is in this case it's
mostly tuning
how many things we want to remove so in
this case with near zero variants
i uh tuned the two parameters to
basically decide what type of
columns we want to keep and also the
threshold for the correlated variables
so we'll see that basically in the other
plots
below as for the actual models
i created three different models for
both the classification
and uh regression problems uh this is
what i usually start out with anyways
i usually do an elastic model uh what's
what's called like an elastic net model
so generally just tune the mixture and
penalty parameter
um actually boost model and a random
force model
we're actually boost i've kind of i
usually tune a little bit more
parameters but in this case i want to
just tune
learn rate number of trees i will often
tune the tree depth
but again this is just an example i
don't really care about predictive power
that much i just want to use it to
get some plots and then finally we do
the random forest model
in this case i just want to plot the uh
the r2 and the number of trees so
nothing too crazy over there
um one thing you might notice is that
the xgb's running force models
um the only thing that changes is the
mode
right but for the elastic models you
need to specify
linear or religious regression uh for
the uh
um uh or the classification and i
actually need to
change these things specification cool
um okay so for the actual metrics i'm
going to do your typical
um predictive modeling metrics so
classification
roc aoc and accuracy regression
root mean squared error mean absolute
error and r squared
and also set up a model control because
i'm going to do some
stacking for the models because i
obviously with
um slice going on people are really
getting into these um
ensembled models or stacked models so i
figured i'd show you
a nice plot that you can use when you're
doing your model stacking
um usually these parameters or these
metrics are included
inside of your tuning process however
when
you're using the fine-tune package you
kind of need to specify
the primers you want to optimize based
off of so in this case
uh you have to you have to show your
first parameter as the thing that
fine tune will choose so in this case
we're going to prioritize roc aoc
and for our regression problems we want
to prioritize root mean squared error
okay um i also experiment with this
other
package which is i think a little bit
newer um which is workflow sets
i think this is actually a really good
package the only thing i wish they had
was a model control process um so that
way if you're going to tune a lot of
models you might want to save the
predictions
um so with classification set um
in this case i didn't really feel like
saying the predictions i just want to
show an example
in case you were actually doing with
workflow sets the included plots that
are with it
but um it's essentially doing the same
thing that i've always done
which you create a list of recipes that
you want to use for all the models
always have all the models that you want
to tune and then you basically use
suicide cross
or crossing you know basically compute
every
pair of recipes and models together you
can also do an anti-join so you can
remove redundant
uh pre-processing model pairs so like
if you have some type of normalization
process it's not necessary for um
you know tree based models and stuff
like that so you can do that but
again let's keep it simple and in this
case instead of
giving it a grid because you might
notice that i don't use any grids
or i don't do i don't create any grids
for the actual models
i use uh tune for using simulated
annealing uh so that'll basically uh
tune it for me
um and then also tune the models um
with different methods so um with the
classification
i wanted to show you how you can use
portfolio sets and use tune with
simulated annealing
um with the elastic model i wanted to
show like an
anova tuning procedure um and also
a bayesian procedure um so these tune
in different ways and then i also did
some basic tuning with you know the
traditional we just give it a grid
when you use tune grid you can either
give it a grid or it'll just
automatically tune with the predefined
grid that they just kind of include with
the models
so i just left it like that and then
finally we actually have the results
uh for me i just like combined all the
models into a single
table or data frame and then i basically
extracted the top
root mean squared error from each model
i mean you can see that you know what we
would expect
xgb's performs better random force
performs pretty good
and elastic model performs a little bit
worse than those non-linear
models which is not you know surprising
at all
okay so now we're actually go into the
actual plotting
so this is the workflow set or where we
basically tuned
all of the model and recipe pairings so
if i do that with the auto plot
we can actually get a pretty nice plot
right here we're just showing
you know each um rank of the models
because you have to realize that
we're using different parameters for the
models but we can kind of see that
you know logistic regression or our
elastic model
has the higher um accuracy and also
higher rc
aoc scores and you can kind of see it
kind of drop off
um one thing that's pretty interesting
is we can see like a definitive like uh
kind of a grouping where you know
they're not they're obviously not
this very similar um you i think would
just
they'll just regression model is
definitely the best so you know that's a
pretty nice
uh handy way to basically extract
everything we really want
out of these workflow sets and get like
a high level overview before we start
looking
at the actual models um parameters
so i also do the i rank the results so
we can kind of get a nice little
um thing for it so we can see that yep
our regular elastic model is the best
pretty high rank um and we can see that
rdc
c scores are pretty stable okay
um one of the things i also want to do
is kind of just compare these two models
so i figured you know we'll just extract
um
the best parameters for both the elastic
and random force model
and we'll tune it later to basically use
the tighty posterior package to
basically compare the models
so that's just me grabbing them out um
just so i can hard code them out
now we can go back towards our other
tuning procedures so this this model
or this uh twin grid is your typical
tune grid where you give it a grid
or you give it a grid length and it
tunes the model and what's nice about it
is we have a nice little auto plot
function
where we can see when we actually go
back here
uh where we can see kind of like a
faceted chart
of all of the parameters and kind of its
relationship
with our metrics that we want to analyze
so
let's kind of go one by one i think
obviously we want to probably
look at our rooming squared error but
realistically root mean squared error i
mean absolute error are going to be
correlated together
so with the number of trees we can kind
of see it's a little bit all over the
place
uh unique values and frequency
distribution ratio
again it's with kind of all over the
place but the big thing we can see is
the threshold
right so right now we can see how when
we increase the threshold
uh we can see our root mean squared
error has been decreasing so there seems
to be a lot of noise within
within our features so when we think
about it we might want to go back and do
a little bit more feature elimination
and uh in our recipes and start tuning
more models
cool um right now i'm gonna also plot uh
show you the nice little plotting
function
um using the uh uh was it the uh
uh i think this is the uh yeah this is
the uh
uh race anova so instead of using um
uh yeah so we're using tune race anova
which uses the nova scores
um and we can see this how um you know
the race
generally you can see a little bit more
um
separability between the lines but we
can see that you know
um how it's the tuning function has gone
on through it
again this for the uh race anova it's
not as interesting
but it still might be useful for other
uh other
model analysis you know if you see
someone uh
see some uh jagged uh lines
between each of the lines you might have
to consider that uh your k-fold
cross-validation set
is uh running into problems okay
so this is the tune base
so instead of using the race anova or
the rare grid i'm using some bayesian
analysis
where it's basically kind of going
through iterations and saying like how
much of a
unexpected increase in performance i
think
so we can see the iterations and where
it's going um
here and we see how the more iterations
it's kind of uh
it's decreasing uh our mean absolute
error mean rooting squared error
so we might want to consider running
with more um
uh uh iterations what's nice about the
auto plot is there are diff there are
different commands
um mostly with very specific things so
um
with performance you need to have some
type of iterative process for you
for your tuning grid but if you do
parameters um again this is the same
thing
as our regular auto pot with our radar
tune grids so
again if we reload it uh
yep we can see again
the threshold makes sense proportion of
last upper uh thing
kind of makes sense you know there's
there probably is some interactions
between
the alaska penalty and regularization um
so uh yeah again pretty interesting
and then lastly let's go to marshalls
um right there oops
so yeah you can see that again not too
interesting
but there's different ways to basically
view your own
tuning results okay
so this is a i think this is a pretty
interesting
way to do it and i also think most time
you should be looking at these types of
plots just how your parameters
you know the overall trend of your
parameters are going uh so that way
you can kind of keep on tuning your
model or or at least like tune
uh specific parameters in a more
informed manner
instead of just tuning it all using just
like uh
the pairwise or using the crossing
function to get all the the
combinations so i wanted to also do
some more classification plots so with
the classification plots i needed to
basically refit
the two models uh so that i could
compare them together and also
so i could you know create the
classification plots using the confusion
matrices and stuff like that
was tuned simulated annealing um there's
no way to specify the control
at least with workflow sets uh so i just
refit
um to models using k-folds
cross-validation
um right here so i just fit three
samples and then i specify the control
which is save pred
equals true or say predictions equals
true um
so i want to show you um a few things
maybe do i
okay a few things so once we have these
things
um once we have our predictions from our
plots
we can collect our predictions right
so when we collect our predictions we
can get the ids of the folds so each
fold the predictions the probability of
that class predictions
and stuff like that and we can create a
few different plots
so the first plot i think we can do are
your general curves so like a gain curve
roc
curve and a lift curve in this case you
just use the functions
um truth equals the outcome of the class
that's actually true
estimate is the probability um
and then you just do autoplot so again
that's pretty cool
um you can also do like lift curves too
and precision recall curves i just
wanted to do
i guess curves i think are more uh
useful so uh gain curve
again pretty good it's like the milk
skimming thing where you do like the top
percentage of
uh top most probable um predictions and
then you extract the percentage found
your typical roc curve just how well um
your model is doing in predictive power
and then you have lift curves
um i'm not really someone who uses a lot
of lift curves
but i wanted to kind of demonstrate how
you can um collect the predictions
and do summarize equals false um
and that way we can actually group by id
i don't think you actually need to do uh
rise equals false up
uh you can uh group by the actual id or
the folds
and then do the lift curve and then
autoplot it and autoplot is smart enough
to
understand that since we have these ids
they'll plot each
id's lift curve so that might be good
when you want to like kind of assess
model stability and stuff like that so
maybe it's not great for lift curves but
for like roc curves it's probably pretty
useful
like maybe we can just do that right now
um just to show you guys
group by id right and we can see
you know there are some fools that we do
really good on and some bowls that we
don't do great on
um which makes sense i guess i forgot to
do
a confusion matrix one so i'll just do
that right now
um with the confusion matrix i think
it's a little bit odd
so if we you must filter the id so
fold equals zero one and then you can do
a comp
mat and then uh oops
and then you do a complement uh class
or was it truth is equal to class
estimate equals dot
class and then you can do an auto plot
so the first one is the like mosaic
which i'm not really a fan of but you
can also do like
uh i think uh heat map
and then you can kind of see your
typical um confusion matrix so
again i don't really like it too much um
i also run into some problems with
you know wanting to do infusion matrix
resampled so if i do this
say conf matt resample
it won't do it um
so maybe i can just
yeah so i don't know why it does this
sometimes
but uh i i just couldn't get it to work
let me see if i can just do one more
time truth equals class
estimate close.red class
yeah so maybe i can
one more try yeah so we do that and then
even when you do an auto plot it doesn't
work because it's not supported so
kind of a weird um but
um weirdly doesn't work
okay well for some reason complement
resample or
you know base taking the average of each
all ten confusion matrices from your
k-fold cross-validation
um sets uh doesn't work with autoplot
but they give you a nice little
thing where it's a simple um gm tile
with the gm label
but again i'm not gonna really sleep
over that
um so i think with your typical uh
modeling workflow you kind of feel your
curves you know you send it over to your
marketing team or
sales team or whatever um for a for a
presentation
and then you kind of have to decide you
know hey what if you have these two
models
who um are very similar in predictive
power
so in this case i guess we'll just say
our elastic model and our random force
model
um how should we uh how should we like
how should we really choose these uh in
between these models uh
we'll just join them up together and
we'll use the perf mod from the tidy
posterior package
and that'll basically give us a nice
little
comparison um what's nice is you can
just do a simple auto plot
and kind of see the distribution of
um the scores and then we can also do
a um difference so we can see like
what's the difference between
you know our elastic models um roc aoc
performance with the random force
and then we can get the actual
probabilities of it being better
um which is pretty useful but um just
using
a basic intuition we know that you know
elastic models are simpler than random
force models
it has safely better performance in my
opinion so we would just choose the
elastic model
but pretty nice plots to create very
quick way to actually analyze your
your models and try to decide which type
of model you want to use
in your final decision
so um now we can actually go to model
stacking
um in this case um i just wanted to you
know combine these two results from our
random forest model
and our xg boost model um that kind of
makes sense at least
from like a kaggle style competition if
we note
uh we can see our control that i've put
in when i was tuning these models was
model control
and model control is a control stack
grid
so that's why i'm able to use these
tuning results inside a stack
so maybe if you don't really want to
choose a model you just want to combine
uh together and create a final model for
like a calgary competition
we'll just add the candidates on the
predictions and then we can kind of
analyze
our actual ensemble model so we can get
some
nice little diagnostics on like number
of members um and the
average um so we can see how it's
changing with our penalty because we're
tuning
essentially an uh i think a lasso model
or it was an elastic
net model onto our stack
so we can see how you know our penalty
uh
has has influenced the results from our
model
our our stacked model um again what's
nice about auto pot we have different
types so
in this case i don't really matter that
this one doesn't really matter that much
so we only need that i think the one
that's the most useful
is the weights uh so if you see a type
equals weights for
an auto pot with a stacked uh model we
can see that
our boosted tree you know it it has the
most it
has the highest weight so it's it's the
one that we want to it's going to use
the most
which is pretty nice you know we're
actually using a variety of different i
guess xg boosts and random force models
but we can see that x2 boost model um
has the best
uh performance and weight so that's one
other way we can actually
uh do some decision making when we're
comparing models is we can kind of set
up
uh essentially a stacked model even
though if we don't really care about the
stack model
we can use these essential model weights
as a way to decide what type of model
which model is the best model right so
that's a thing you commonly see
in uh the brms package for example
um and i think we yeah if we look at it
we can see obviously actually bruce has
the better performance
pro root mean square error um
estimate so if we're going to do that
you know maybe we also want to see some
variable importance scores so
we know that hey our render our actually
boost model
is great at predicting sale price of a
house um
let's extract the one with best for mean
squared error
and then let's actually find like the
actual variable importance to figure out
why it's thinking that so
i just created a simple workflow
combined it uh added a
xg boost model that has no tuning
parameters the
recipe that was for it and then we just
select the best
xg boost model that was using the
regular recipe
and we want to choose the one with the
best root mean square error
then we fit it to the actual data we
pull the actual
model fit object and then we just pull
put it back into the vip package
and then we can see our uh variable
importance
scores where i can see like hey
we think the garage cars is one of the
most uh important aspect of the actual
model
when predicting sale price i think
there's
something great whether it's like a
great living area total basement you
know how
young was the house uh year it was
remodeled
fireplaces you know second floor first
four square footage so
again all the stuff makes sense right
you know number of if
and if you think also it's probably
pretty uh related to each other like
if a house has a ton of space for cars
it probably has a pretty big square
footage
right pretty big lot area um so yeah
that makes sense
um and we can also do the vi function
which will kind of show it in the
positive and negative
so what contributes a huge decrease in
value
and what contributes to a huge increase
in value but it won't actually show the
uh
like the uh the score of it so
yeah um i know this was a pretty quick
video and also it was pretty simple
because it was
pretty minimal code but i think this is
a pretty good script to kind of look at
and kind of
see how tidy models works and how all
the plotting functions work
so that way we can kind of minimize
redundant plotting code
in our um in our like our markdown
documents and stuff like that
that being said um there's always a
there's always a need to make your own
custom plots and
that's why i'm going to make a video
soon going over
all about the grammar of grammar of
graphics with ggplot2
so i'm pretty excited for that video and
i'll record it and post it
after this video so i'll see you guys
next time and
tidy on